hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com
and today we're going to be going over
the brussels gambit which is a variation
in the sicilian defense so it starts out
with
e4 c5 the sicilian
and then after knight two f three black
plays the move
pawn two f five this is the brussels
game bit many times i'll make a video on
a gambit and show you all the fun ways
that you can play that gambit
now you can catch your opponent off
guard and it's going to be a lot of fun
this video is going to be a bit
different because
playing as black i really don't
recommend playing the brussels gambit
in any capacity and so this video is
going to be more about
how white should attack the brussels
game but if your opponent ever decides
to surprise you with this opening so
white is going to take this pawn right
here on f5 sometimes you may see pawn
pushing forward to
e5 but i recommend taking this pawn here
on f5 and so we're going to be looking
at the variations that black could
continue
from here and how white should respond
you could see
d5 opening up for this light square
bishop here you could see
knight to c6 pretty common in the
sicilian defense
knight to f6 trying to develop on the
king side as well or maybe something
basic
like d6 solidifying the pawn chain
opening up for the slight square bishop
so those are
the variations we're going to be looking
at on how to attack
the brussels gambit
i also want to touch on why i think this
is a bad opening for black usually with
the gamut you have some sort of
compensation whether that's a
tempo advantage you have a strong attack
against your opponent there's something
that you're trying to get for giving up
that pawn and material
and this almost looks like a king's
gambit play where you give up that
f-pawn
but in the king's gambit there's a
couple things that are different about
this one is black goes second
and so they're already down a move but
also
you they had their first move as c5
and so this doesn't do anything for the
king's gambit play which is
develop very quickly to the king side of
the board open up the center pawn so you
can get your bishops involved into the
game
and so black's really down two moves if
they're playing
that sort of opening like the king's
gambit where you get your rook here to
f8
have a strong attack on the semi-open
file if you look at it here the most
aggressive pieces
usually in these gambits is the bishops
well all the bishops are blocked off
here by the two central ponds have not
moved at all
you can get the knights involved and so
we'll look at what that looks like but
you can tell
all this has really done is weakened the
king side of the board now it has
removed
the central e pawn for white
but it's just now moved over here to f5
and it's a troublesome square that we'll
look at here in a minute for how black's
going to deal with so
that's why i don't prefer playing this
at black in any capacity even if it's a
blitz game
but if you're white you play against
sicilian defense it's always good to
understand what do i do if my opponent
throws something
tricky at me
the first version we are going to look
at is d5 this opens up one of the
central pawns and allows this light
square bishop here on c8
to attack this pawn here on f5 so
makes a lot of sense if you can get back
this material that you lost here on f5
get a very powerful piece involved into
the attack
this sounds like a win now anytime you
see
this d-pawn move doesn't matter if it's
d6 or d5
you should be thinking about getting
your bishop here to
b5 putting the opponent in check and
forcing them to make a decision on how
they want to
continue now they could play knight to
c6 they could also play bishop to d7
we'll look at that as well
if they played knight to c6 here which
is a pretty common move then you're
going to be playing knight
to e5 this knight here on c6 is pinned
down to the king anytime you have a
piece pinned down it's always good to
attack
that piece because they can't move and
so this knight here on e5 is a very
strong attack here and there's a couple
ways they could
continue one of the first options is
okay i'm just not going to worry about
this right now i can just play
bishop takes here on f5
well from here white's going to take
here on
c6 and then the pawn takes on
c6 now black could uh they
could try something like queen to b6 and
they'll actually use this in another
variation but i want to show you
what's wrong with this position here
because
you can see this is attacking the bishop
and the knight right here now the knight
wants to move but then the queen could
take the bishop
but white has the move knight to d4 this
is a discoverer to check so the bishop
here on b5 is attacking the king but
also
this knight here on d4 is defending
this bishop here on b5 so the queen
can't just take it because then the
knight would capture
right here so if we look at the
different options one option would just
be
king 2 d8 but now you can see that this
knight here on
d4 can take the bishop on f5
so this is not going to be a very good
position
for black yes they could take the bishop
but you can see black's already lost
two minor pieces doesn't really have a
safe king right here all of a sudden
white can get their queen involved into
the game
very easy for white to dominate this
position now
if black says okay well my king's under
attack i can just
move my bishop back here to d7 you can
but now the queen to h5 and this is a
very difficult
attack for black to deal with they could
play g6 to stop this
now bishop takes on d7 king takes d7 and
now queen over 2
d5 check and now it's very difficult for
black to deal with all of the threats
that we have
so if we come back a few moves instead
of that queen to b6
gonna be much better if they just take
with their pawn here on a c6
uh but now bishop to c6 maybe bishop
here to d7 to protect that
and then bishop takes here on d5 i do
recognize that you could take
this rook here on a8 and then they could
just swing over here and take your
bishop
uh i personally think it's good to
continue
you're still gobbling that material here
so d5
you still have a central bishop right
here you can cast on the king side get
your queen ball into the game
you are winning as white but it is good
to have powerful pieces
still involved into the game you can see
this dark square bishop still can't move
has to do something here and so i really
like this
over taking this rook here on a8
and after the knight comes to e5
attacking that pinned piece here on
c6 black does not have to take here on
f5
they could play knight to f6 white's
still gonna continue with knight takes
here on
c6 and really black needs to be thinking
about queen
to b6 now we talked about before why
that was not a good move
and that was because white had to move
knight to d4
and then that was not only defending
this bishop here on b5 but
also is attacking the bishop that was
here on f5 that's no longer the case
because black did not take that pawn
here on f5
so this is not going to be as good
because now just king 2 d8
and all of a sudden knight 2 e6 this is
an outpost but
okay after the bishops exchange with the
knights
then the queen takes here on b6 this is
not as good so
if in this position knight two d4
is not the move instead white's going to
play the move knight to a7 which looks
somewhat odd but you have to remember
that this is a discovered check so the
bishop here on b5 is putting the black
king in check and also
this knight here on a7 is still
protecting
this bishop here on b5 so the queen
can't take it so
maybe king 2 f7 if this is case knight 2
c8 so it just took a pawn now it's
taking a bishop right here
so even if the queen were to take here
on
b5 that's fine knight to c3 attacking
this queen right here
yes this knight's going to probably fall
but white is up in material and you can
see that this
king is completely exposed and white's
going to be able to attack that for
the rest of the game
if we come back a few moves instead of
king 2 f7 they have other options they
could play king 2 d8
same thing i just go and take their
bishop here on c8
the goal really is to take a pawn and a
bishop just gobble up more material put
their king
in a worse position once the king moves
they can't castle anymore so that's
going to be good
it could also play bishop to d7
this is blocking the bishop in this case
go ahead and take with your bishop
right here after the king takes maybe
queen to
f3 just getting more material involved
into the game and this also
puts a threat on this knight to f6
because if this knight moves it really
exposes this pawn
here on d5 because this knight's the
only piece that's defending it
and then the queen can take here on d5
and you know they could try to use it as
an outpost
knight to e4 at some point why can
castle on the king side if they want to
they could play
knight to c3 at some point black's going
to be using a move up here to take
this knight so white just has to realize
that that knight's gone but still
up in material very good position the
king is exposed
and can really attack that for the rest
of the game
so we come back to this initial setup
after d5 bishop to b5 putting
our opponent in check they could play
bishop to d7 stopping that's fine we're
going to be playing the same thing
knight
to e5 attacking this pinned piece right
here
and the reason i like this is it almost
is baiting them to play the bishop
takes on b5 because why not the problem
is
this is going to fail because white has
the move queen to
h5 check and there's not a lot of great
ways for
black to deal with this you have pawn to
g6 to stop that
pawn takes here on g6 they can't just
take with their pawn because that's
checkmate right there
so we definitely know that that loses so
instead the best move would be
knight to f6 attacking the queen but
okay now we can push forward with
g7 and now when they take our queen we
can take their rook
and promote to a queen right here so you
can see
we've only lost that bishop they've lost
their rook
we've gobbled up some ponds here they've
gobbled up one of our ponds we've taken
two of their pawns
and their king is still in the center of
the board
this dark square bishop's not helping
and it can't move right now because it's
pinned down by this queen
white has a very strong attack can
castle on the king side
play either d3 to block the bishop or
some point
d4 get the dark sure bishop involved
into the game so this is going to be a
pretty easy
game for white so that's why you know
playing the knight to e5
early in that position almost baiting
them to play this bishop takes on
b5 is definitely going to be a good
option now they don't have to take
if they don't take here they could play
knight to f6 we're just gonna take their
bishop here on d7
they pretty much need to take with this
knights if they took with their other
knight that would be terrible because
they were playing the queen two h5 and
we run into the same thing as before
but assuming they take with their
knights here on uh d7 we can just play
d4 preparing to get our door square
bishop to ball involved into the game we
still have our queen threat
at all times so still very very strong
attack that white
has against black
so what if they don't play d5 they're
not looking to get their central pawns
involved into the game get their bishops
involved maybe they want to get their
knights involved so one of those might
be knight to
c6 just start pushing in the center of
the board here d4 and this is very
similar to how you'll normally
be playing the sicilian defenses knight
to f3
pawn pushing forward here to d5 if they
take with their pawn
that's great you just take your with
your knight same as you normally play in
the sicilian defense and you still have
that threat
of queen to h5 now if they don't take
they could play
d5 themselves in this case any time you
see that d-pawn move you should be
thinking
bishop to b5 it's either going to be
check or pinning down material in this
case they played knight to c6 so you're
pinning down this knight right here
you have the thread at some point of
knight to e5 attacking that pin
piece always be looking to attack pin
material if they play
pawn to a6 sure you can just go ahead
and
exchange right here take with their pawn
you can take their pawn here on
c5 that's fine uh if they decide to
maybe take this pawn here on f5 one of
the reasons you play d5
is to play bishop takes here on f5
that's fine you can just take their own
pawn here on
c5 you still have their knight pinned
down so i think this is going to be
a good variation as well maybe they
don't play d5 maybe they play queen to
b6 many times you
play the sicilian and then you want to
try to get your queen over here to its
b6 at some point you can push forward if
you want to
attacking this knight here on uh c6 but
really
i just would take this material here on
c5 if they take with their queen that's
fine bishop 2
d3 castle on the king side you can see
they really haven't made a ton of
improvement in their position this
bishop on d3 also protects the pawn here
on
f5 from this queen so all in all really
like this
position from white
if they try to get their other knight
involved at the beginning of the game
knight to f6
really the only option i see here you're
going to continue same thing
pawn 2 d4 same as a normal sicilian
defense you're attacking in the center
with d4
if they play d5 same as before bishop
to b5 check if they decide to take
knight takes here on d4 which we are
used to seeing here
if they play their knight you have a lot
of different options as far as what you
want to do but if they play
d5 same as before bishop two b5
check and even if we come back to the
very beginning maybe they don't play
knight to f6 they could just play
a d6 bishop to b5
check and then depending on where they
go you have lots of options here
uh the one thing that's going to be
different is you don't have the move
knight to e5 to attack that pinned piece
here
if they play like knight two c6 so just
be aware of that you don't want to lose
your knight right away but you can
castle on the king side
you can attack the center of the board
with d4 to get your dark square bishop
involvements of the game so a lot of
different options
but at the end of the day the brussels
game but not something i recommend
as black and i love a good gambit i love
to catch my opponent off guard
if you have enough compensation even if
you're just playing a rapid or a blitz
game
i do like to find gambits that i can
find an edge
the brussels game but i don't think that
is the case so
you may not run into it all that often
but you definitely may see it if you run
against
the sicilian defense hopefully this
video gave you an idea of how to attack
uh the brussels gambit if you ever run
into it so thank you guys so much for
watching if you haven't already
hit the like button let me know what you
thought of this video in the comments
section also if there's other videos you
want
me to go over let me know in the
comments if you have questions about the
video or any of the variations
you can also ask me that in the comments
i will be
replying to all those as well so thanks
again i'll see you in
the next video